[Musica]
[Applauso]
un colpo solo pronti aa fantastico di
nuovo pronti siete bravissimi
quanti di voi hanno delle chiavi in
tasca tanti di voi nella borsetta tanti
tiratele fuori tutti
siamo alla fine fate un piccolo sforzo
ok al mio gesto è il mio gesto sarà
questo per indicarvi le chiavi di usarle
e quindi le userete immagino
un colpo solo con le chiavi
pronti
[Applauso]
ho un corpo solo di mani questa sarà
gesto per le mani pronti avete questo
tutti la vetta
io sono sicuro che se vi chiedo di fare
questo ce la fate tutti giusto la
risposta giusta era sì al tuo segnale
pronti un colpo solo con le mani adesso
facciamo un gioco tipo gioca jouer
pronti un colpo solo con le mani
perfetto avete già imparato quasi tutto
quello che vi servirà più tardi
avrò davvero bisogno della vostra
concentrazione e della vostra
partecipazione per cui tenete a mente i
segni che abbiamo appena usato e ci
divertiremo improvvisare ha cambiato il
mio modo di pensare di ascoltare e di
suonare è un'attività che facciamo
quotidianamente quando parliamo
camminiamo scriviamo ma esercitarla
consciamente approfondirla come pratica
se stante nel mio caso come genere
musicale a sé stante ci porta a
ragionare in modo più elastico più
predisposto all'allattamento ea
migliorare la nostra flessibilità
cognitiva
questo ci porta anche a sviluppare ea
migliorare la nostra capacità creativa e
di problem solving che sono due qualità
piuttosto rilevanti in campo artistico è
cambiato il mio modo di ascoltare perché
la musica
se analizzata come un dialogo tra
musicisti e tra musicista e pubblico
vive fortemente di questa dimensione
improvvisare focalizza l'attenzione
sull'ascolto per per permetterci di
cogliere ogni minima variazione sonora e
poter interagire con quella minima
variazione suonare in modo profondo e
attento spesso facendo musica ci
concentriamo prevalentemente sul fare un
discorso di senso compiuto e
ascoltandola di cercare di seguire quel
filo discorsivo ecco a me interessano di
più concentrarmi su un suono sul suono
in sé esplorandolo ed approfondendolo vi
faccio vi faccio un semplicissimo
esempio
provate a pronunciare al mio segnale
provate a pronunciare più volte secondo
il vostro tempo alla parola sasso
marcando fortemente le consonanti e
quasi non pronunciando le vocali fatelo
fatelo e provate ad ascoltarvi ad
ascoltare il suono nell'insieme formato
da ognuno di voi in sostanza provate ad
ascoltare
l'effetto sonoro che a quella parola
quindi pronti
ora questa parte
avanti con questa parte questa parte
provi a pronunciare soltanto le focali
di quella parola quindi a o a o forza
forza stato lo state facendo in troppo
pochi
ecco questo è un minuscolo inizio un
minuscolo approccio su come esplorare un
suono anche se a livello di significato
non avete fatto altro che ripetere
pietra roccia sasso appunto e
l'improvvisazione ha infine cambiato e
influenzato il mio modo di suonare
perché mette in dubbio quello che so sul
mio strumento spingendomi a farmi
domande a ricercare soluzioni e diverse
più personali a non seguire strade già
battute e in sostanza è principalmente a
mettere il suono prima di ogni cosa
specialmente prima dell'ego un po di
tempo fa ho iniziato a suonare ed
esibirmi in solo questo è successo anche
per la difficoltà nel trovare compagni
di avventure sono nato e cresciuto a
bolzano e 12 anni fa mi sono trasferito
a padova e nessuna di queste due città
c'è mai stata una scena di questo tipo
di musica o un folto numero di musicisti
che la praticasse e cercare di eliminare
lo stress e la frustrazione che derivava
da questa situazione non felicissima
sicuramente è stato uno degli elementi
che mi ha spinto verso questa scelta il
suonare è da solo ha dei vantaggi non
devi rendere conto di nulla nessuno ci
sei solo tu e il tuo strumento non devi
ascoltare altri pareri e opinioni
in sostanza della band 6 litri del
comprimario il manager il produttore e
l'autista gli svantaggi ahimè
corrispondono esattamente ai vantaggi e
riflette riflettendoci nel tempo ho
notato che questo questo approccio mi
avrebbe portato forse a chiudermi a
isolarmi non risolvendo per niente la
situazione in cui mi trovavo lasciandola
invariata
così ho deciso di fondare un laboratorio
ed un'orchestra nel laboratorio insegno
e condivido le mie conoscenze
sull'improvvisazione cercando di creare
il clima e l'ambiente che mi sarebbe
piaciuto vivere da studente e che in
parte ho avuto la fortuna di vivere e
questo non è molto difficile perché io
stesso imparo moltissimo e la
condivisione di un sapere non è mai un
fatto unilaterale
e spesso credo di tornare a casa con
addirittura più con più informazioni e
stimoli di quanti ne riceverà i miei
studenti sia al laboratorio che
l'orchestra mi permettono di testare e
sperimentare idee che sarebbero
altrimenti impraticabili e tramite
queste idee cerco di far germogliare il
seme della curiosità freddo verso questo
genere musicale
in sostanza si può dire che questo sia
mio tentativo per creare di creare una
scena per risolvere una mancanza che
percepivo gestire tutto questo
l'organizzazione dei workshop dei
musicisti
è uno sforzo notevole è sicuramente più
faticoso che suonare da sole ma credo
che in questo caso valga la regola
generale che maggiori gli sforzi
maggiori le ricompense dirigo
l'orchestra attraverso dei segni di cui
quelli che abbiamo provato prima
sono una piccola parte è un linguaggio
che è stato sviluppato da un incredibile
musicista butch morris con lo scopo di
poter dirigere comporre allo stesso
tempo lasciando però ai musicisti la
libertà di interpretare e soddisfare i
segni del direttore d'orchestra è un
linguaggio che stimola incentiva
fortemente la creatività e la
collettività come vi avevo detto
all'inizio sarete chiamati a partecipare
non dubitatene tenetevi pronti e
ascoltiamo cosa riusciamo a creare
insieme grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]
quell'uomo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
un uomo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
tu tu tu tu tu tu
[Applauso]
[Musica]
bene
[Applauso]
[Risate]
[Musica]
[Applauso]